you know it's so cool the way that i met
ethan
i i uh one night i forget one video
led to another video i went down a
youtube rabbit hole
i'm like what's this [ __ ] h3h3 [ __ ] i
love it man it's like the [ __ ]
internet police
busting kooks for faking pranks and
stuff
and i'm like dude this is great so then
i just went ahead and i got on twitter
and i was like yo i just i tweeted i
just became a huge fan
of h3h3 yoe then what's up
and like in in short order ethan hit me
back
i was like man this is the way to like
you know network and meet cool celebrity
friends yeah
yeah i had never done that before i
don't think so then he hit me back we
exchanged cell numbers
we got together i remember the first
time that we met in person i drove out
to his house and uh
and and we were talking about youtube
and all the fake pranks was a topic of
conversation
and i was like man there were these two
guys who were very established youtubers
who who helped collaborate with me to
launch my channel
you know like i'm gonna film with them
on their channel they're gonna drive to
my channel and it's gonna be great
and and so we're figuring out what are
we gonna film oh we'll go film a
prank you know and they're gonna think
well what's the prank gonna be
and they're like oh man we can just fake
it and i was like
what yeah he's like what yeah exactly
like i'm like dude
i said you guys don't [ __ ] understand
if i fake one
[ __ ] thing ever then all of the
things i've ever done in my career come
into question there's absolutely no way
would
ever [ __ ] fake were they
we can't say any names i think that like
anybody could look at at how i launched
my channel
i mean and plus it was a [ __ ]
vitality okay
yeah he's admitted he has since admitted
that some of his pranks were fake so
there was okay
[Laughter]
yeah well it was a really big topic on
youtube was all these dudes started
faking their pranks and um everybody
knew it
but it's funny because vitaly always
held like on the original pre
you seen his crazy coke-filled uh grant
that that was like oh my god it was
pretty great yeah
he says like and he's like like five of
the videos i've ever made were fake
yeah it's one of my favorite videos ever
dude it's brand new oh he met he name
drops to you he goes uh
wrote me a letter and he says that he
loves bee he was like
so none of y'all [ __ ] [ __ ] can say
[ __ ] i i do i do remember that what it
was was like
he had just gotten in the ring with the
ball and the ball broke his jaw
oh yeah that's right and i and i was
like what and i i remember had 10.
pretty good
yeah i texted him i was like dude with
the [ __ ] bull dude i was like
battalion you're the real deal
so he takes he takes like he's a fake
bowl
he he i i i think that's what it was i
texted him yo
you're the real deal because he got in
the [ __ ] with the bull yeah and then he
says
you see stevo says i'm the real deal
like as if it was a comment about his
pranks being real
yeah yeah yeah that's awesome yeah was
that you that called out that one dude
that was like going up to random chicks
and like
it's been like yeah you want to make out
dude prank convention
yeah yeah yeah prank invasion i have a
long
and colorful history with prank invasion
uh he's a great one he did famously
mommy make out day
on venice i loved that video god i loved
that video so much then there was the
the legendary joey salads i think what's
most incredible about
about ethan here is that he'll
just eviscerate destroy
these these youtubers but then like
turn around and have them on this
podcast and they're blowing down
yeah that's a pretty impressive talent
to be able to
essentially destroy somebody's
livelihood and then have a laid-back
conversation with them on your
podcast well i hope i'm not destroying
their livelihood but
i know what you mean they're not like
friendly videos but i agree i mean i
like meeting people
the person that they are because you
know ultimately they're just dudes for
the most part like most of these guys i
met are really
good normal dudes vitaly you know he
he's an exception obviously he just beat
the [ __ ] out of some random woman he's
in jail and [ __ ]
and floyd's crazy oh [ __ ] yeah didn't he
but like
i saw that but i didn't know how real it
was oh my god no it was real
he beat up he beat up a woman allegedly
he allegedly beat up a woman like really
and he's got
you think that the the one cook field
like uh
calling out the fake pranks video or
whatever it was was gnarly he's got the
most legendary mug shot of all time
why what is it oh my god
yeah he he allegedly you know the
stories he went into a roid rage
and he started beating the [ __ ] out of a
random woman
decimated he's [ __ ] jacked too like
he can do some damage
yeah he's like but anyway most peop
everyone but vitaly
why is my siri keep going off what is
this
sorry these are last things
i've reached that point of uncomfortable
where we're talking negatively
i mean i think okay but it wasn't i was
about to talk positively
yeah okay good so i was gonna say with
the exception of a tally
everybody just said he's gonna come kill
me now
yeah fresh out of jail he's gonna stab
you everybody
else who's come through which is most of
the pranksters we've talked about
end up being really sweet we have good
rapport and we have great conversations
you know so
so um joey salt is a really nice guy
like i text with him he's [ __ ]
dumb as hell but i say that to him he's
like the dumbest person man yeah
but he's super sweet and he wouldn't
take offense to that there's definitely
uh a correlation like
between stupidity and sweetness
like a puppy dumb people can be
really lovely i think there's it's more
common the dumber the nicer right
that's probably true yeah it's like
almost like a child like
demeanor i'll tell you intelligence is a
[ __ ] liability i used to say this all
the time
you know like uh history what do we know
about history
the [ __ ] [ __ ] repeats itself it's all
bad news and it's definitely going to
repeat itself
so the more you know the more bad news
you know the more [ __ ]
the intelligence gets you nowhere except
it makes you miserable
ignorance is bliss it really is no it
really is you know and
they say they say that the more
intelligent people are more prone to
depression
they do say that i think alcohol i don't
know who they are and i don't know where
they said it i think they tried that
once
are uh tend to be smarter um
so so i met up with ethan and it was
great like we had to wait a real good
laugh we were
you know i remember this i believe that
that was
2017 when uh ethan and i hooked up
we had a little bromance going we may
have made a youtube video
i haven't particularly thought it was so
funny smash the like button
we got into this whole thing kind of
smashed that like button
so hard and yeah this being desperate
for likes like uh
yeah i couldn't quite understand the
whole thing
you know i felt like i still feel like
i'm a youtuber but kind of looking at
youtube from a little bit of a
of a side perspective but um we made a
youtube video
which got demonetized where
we made like a ball a fake ball sack
which was actually filled with blood and
i pulled it out of my
jeans and like with the scissors cut off
the ball sack and all these bloods going
everywhere it was like
it was pretty evidently fake it was
super fake but
youtube doesn't [ __ ] around with that
kind of stuff and well i'm happy to say
i don't i don't know of any other
mainstream youtube video where someone
gets castrated like that
yeah groundbreaking right and i think it
was
yeah whatever and now the video that
that was
in was like one it was like a pretty
serious topic it was a
family of five or whatever like the
daddy of five the kid was flinching at
the
person yelling oh that [ __ ] was awful
yeah daddy of five
did can you give us an update on what
happened with the the daddy of five
folks
oh yeah you know what um he made i think
he made a new channel called
hold on he made a new channel i think
he's back on youtube
and it's called it's called daddy on his
own because
i think it's called father of six or
something
i swear to god i swear to god hold on
daddy five new channel daddy oh
five were there not criminal charges
brought against them
yeah no they got they got totally uh he
lost
i think he lost his kids some of his
kids
and god i don't remember but yeah he
he definitely got in trouble with the
law see i'm seeing daddy
the martin boys looks like he changed
the channel name he's back
the martin boys yeah that was it i if i
recall correctly it was the mom
who was more abusive they were both
shitty people
and that that was just one of the
you know youtube goes to these peaks of
and valleys of uh
tremendous fads and that was one of the
weirder ones was abusing your kids
for youtube views which was one of the
more interesting fads i've witnessed on
youtube and i'm glad we were there
to comment on it did he get in trouble
because you commented on it
like did you expose that i wasn't the
only one i was far from the only one
philly d was the one that was really
going in on him and he and they had like
beef it was pretty cool
yeah you're in the community yeah dude
um so
like if your videos have essentially
like
taken on you know like to you're like
the internet police you're busting
people for being
shitty people and and doing wrong things
like if that's had a detrimental effect
on the the subjects of your videos
probably the higher end of the
detrimental effect would be daddy of
five so i participated
in probably the most destructive h3h3
videos
that's safe to say
yeah dude